افد مراسل الجزيره باندلاع اشتباكات قويه
بين مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوه الاحتلال خلال
اقتحامها مدينه جنين ومخيمها وقد دفعت
قوات الاحتلال بتعزيزات عسكريه اضافيه الى
المدينه وحاصرت احياء عده فيها وسط
اشتباكات مع المقاومين تخللها القاء عبوات
ناسفه تجاه القوات المقتحمه وشنت قوات
الاحتلال حمله دهم وتفتيش لمنازل
المواطنين واعتقلت ثمانيه فلسطين
معنا الان من جنين الصحفي عليا السمودي
اهلا بك علي كيف يبدو الوضع في جنين
الان نعم نعم نحن الان على ابواب الحي
الشرقي هذا الحي الذي شهد فجر اليوم
اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه وكما تلاحظون في
خلفيتي هذا اثار الدمار الذي خلفه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في هذا الحي اضافه
الى العديد من احياء مدينه ومخيم جنين
طبعا قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كانت قد
اقتحمت مدينه الجنين باكثر من 50 اليه
معززه بالجرافات وبطائق المسيره التي حلقت
على ارتفاع منخفض هذه القوات رغم الانتشار
واحتلال المنازل ونصب القناصه واطلاق
النار على كل جسم يتحرك الا انها جوبهت
بمقاومه عنيفه مقاتلين من كتيبه جنين
وكتائب شهداء الاقصى وكتائب القسام تصدوا
لقوات الاحتلال ابتداء من الحي الشرقي
وحليمه السعديه والبيادر والمراح حتى وسط
المدينه ومخيم جنين وبالتالي ما شهدناه
كما قلت كانت مواجهات هي عنيفه والاعنف
منذ فتره رغم ان قوات الاحتلال قامت
بعمليات دهم وتفتيش طبعا تبين من خلال
متابعتنا لهذه العمليه ان الهدف من
هذه هذه العمليه الاسرائيليه هو توجيه
رسائل تحدير وتهديد لدوي المقاومين بتص
تصفيتهم واعدامهم اذا لم يسلموا انفسهم
هذا اضافه الى تكبيد المواطنين والمجتمع
المحلي ومواطني جنين خسائر فادحه من خلال
تدمير البنيه التحتيه كما تلاحظين هذا
الشارع في الحي الشرقي قرب المقبره هو
شارع حيوي ورئيسي يعيش في هذه المنطقه
الاف المواطنين وهو المدخل الوحيد الذي
يربطهم في المدينه قامت جرافات الاحتلال
بتدميره كما جرفت مناطق اخرى وشوارع اخرى
اضافه الى الدوار الرئيسي دوار الشهيد ابو
علي مصطفى ودوار السينما لكن الابرز هنا
ان قوات الاحتلال عادت لتنفذ هذه العمليه
بعد فقط ساعات من انتهاء عمليه التاهيل
والتحضير لتعبيد الشوارع في مدينه ومخيم
جنين الان هنالك صوره وكارثه رهيبه نراها
في مخيم جنين لان الاحتلال دمر الشوارع
مره اخرى وبالتالي خاصه الشوارع في محيط
ميدان الشهيده شيرين ابو عقلي ودوار
العوده هنالك حيث يتوجه طلبه المخيم الى
مدارس الوكاله اليوم اليوم اعتقد انهم لن
يتمكنوا من الدوام والوصول الى مدارسهم
بسبب الدمار الذي خلفه الاحتلال الذي
اقتحم المنازل واعتقل عدد من الفلسطينيين
قالت اسرهم انهم ليسوا بمطلوب ولكن الاهم
انه اقتحم منازل عدد من المقاومين من
كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي اعتقل
اثنين منهم وقام بتهديد اسرهم بتصفيتهم
واعدامهم اذا لم يسلموا انفسهم طبعا مره
اخرى ومنذ حوالي شهرين عملي الاحتلال تم
ولا تتمكن قوات الاحتلال من الوصول الى
المقاومين رغم كل ما تمارسه من حصار
ومضايقات على جنين التي تعيش انهيار
اقتصادي بسبب الحصار المفروض منذ احداث
السابع من اكتوبر الصحفي علي سمودي من
جنين شكرا
جزيلا